[Music]
here at the Amber Ruffin show we're
committed to bringing you all of the
latest news but we're also committed to
bringing you surprise guests that will
blow your freaking mind and we have one
of those here with us tonight I can't
believe this guest is in our studio
right now and that I'm going to get to
hang out with her I'm medically speaking
freaking out please welcome Jasmine Guy
wow
[Applause]
hi thank you for being here I love you
terribly Jasmine I'm so excited that
you're here I've been a fan of yours for
approximately one million years I love
everything you've ever been in and I
pre-love the things you haven't been in
yet welcome wow that was great thank you
thank you for loving me in the future
yeah I love you in the future I love you
in the past I love you most of all right
now no that's
has had an incredible acting career from
hard-hitting dramas to Broadway musicals
to the iconic sitcom a different world
Ms guy has done it all baby
Jasmine
what
this this has to happen to you
everywhere you freaking go
um Jasmine what is your favorite role
you've ever played oh
I love playing Roxy on Dead Like Me that
was a Showtime series and
um I love playing Velma in the Musical
Chicago
[Applause]
well we're gonna find out right now in a
game called a different read
[Music]
here's how it's gonna work
all kinds of dialogue and after each
line I'll call out different acting
Styles and Jasmine will say the line in
each of those Styles thus demonstrating
the mind-blowing depths of her acting
range Jasmine are you ready I am okay
your first line is Oh no I got a stain
on my shirt please say it in the style
of sitcom
Oh no I got a stain on my shirt
and now
drama
oh no
that stain on my shirt
[Applause]
news
and Justin I've got a stain on my shirt
perfection
Jasmine Guy your next line is give me
the fifty dollars you owe me
let's hear it in the style of a Tyler
Perry movie
you better give me my fifty dollars
[Applause]
in the style of a children's show
give me my fifty dollars give me
give me my fifty dollars give me
excuse me
hahaha
and let's hear that line in the style of
a Telenovela
please give me my denial
[Applause]
correct okay okay
[Applause]
where's my baby she was right here a
minute ago
let's hear it in the sort of a true
crime documentary
where's my baby
she was right here a minute ago
a stoner comedy
this is my baby
you were just right here
[Applause]
of a western
words my baby
she was just tritarian a minute ago
[Applause]
there's a hair in my soup let's hear it
as a NPR reporter
waiter there's a hair
in My Soup
[Applause]
I liked it he has an NPR show let's see
that line as a Noir film
wait
there's a hair
in My Soup
and finally let's hear it in the style
of Broadway
waiter there's a hair where there's a
hair in my soup
[Applause]
Jasmine
do you have any party words of advice
for aspiring actors who look up to you
uh work on your craft love what you do
share your love and believe that you can
go
as I believe in you amazing that's
Jasmine Guy this has been a different
read
[Music]
[Applause]